a busy man no doubt but he is getting it
done on the court with chris paul
chris a disappointing game five how does
this team continue to find the resolve
to bounce back and have an effort like
this to keep your season alive
first i want to give my condolences to
john thompson and that family
he was special he was special my boy
mike russell coaches one of my aau teams
he always coaches our team with a towel
on his shoulders
just because of coach thompson and
another big shout out to our players for
how
they handling everything down here as
men you know i mean with everything
going on and
as far as our team this is who we are
you know what i mean we built for stuff
like this
a lot of guys on our team been you know
pushed out traded or whatnot but we just
stick together and we keep fighting
well it seems like part of your team is
also playing with a chip on your
shoulder a little chippiness there's a
lot of talking out there and
in particular we saw you hit a big shot
and give a little pat to the behind to
the houston rockets
yeah it was uh robert covington shout
out to tennessee state
hbcu you know what i mean gamesmanship
is all respect
love uh love my teammates dennis
schroeder is a dog
it's a dog i go down play against
anybody with him any day and our team
man
you know when it gets to clutch time
fourth quarter some people built for it
some people shy away from it you know
you saw dame
all that stuff like some some people
built for it man and we're just gonna
keep
we're gonna keep hooping all right you
got less than 48 hours a game seven
against your
like it don't matter who it's against
it's a game seven you know what i mean i
just want my guys to know that
you know we we gave ourselves a chance
you know
you know you're saying you're saying we
got a chance we got a chance so
we're gonna keep fighting appreciate it
jared i'm out all right chris you're
saying